[Music]
in 1996 tom cruise accepted the mission
of playing ethan hunt in mission
impossible which would become one of the
biggest film franchises in the world
not just in regards to global gross
where six films have made 3.6 billion
dollars at the box office
but also in cruz's adherence to doing
the amazing stunt work himself
for unique action authenticity which at
830 million dollars spent so far
has made it one of the most expensive
film franchises ever
so your mission if you choose to accept
it is
to just sit back and let us open up the
dossier on the history of the television
series adaptation
and hear all the ways in which crews put
himself in danger for
our entertainment oh don't worry the
video won't self-destruct or anything
i think
mission impossible unspooled 171
episodes during its television series
run from 1966 to 1973
the original show was inspired by the
1964 glitzy heist film
tope copy which emphasized the teamwork
in a ragtag crew of thieves
specifically highlighting the genius use
of electronics and simple objects
to pull off an elaborate robbery like
top copy mission impossible had long
stretches without dialogue focusing on
gadgetry and mechanical ways of
ratcheting suspense
originally show creator bruce geller had
conceived of something that sounded more
like the suicide squad
six former military specialists who
committed covert crimes for the common
good
the hell is wrong with you people we're
bad guys
it's what we do but during the cold war
1960s television just
wasn't ready for anti-heroes so geller
refashioned what he called briggs squad
into the impossible mission force or
imf with american exceptionalism and
heroism put front and center
in the series the imf took on
governments and spies from fictional
places such as the european people's
republic
and the eastern europe republic the
opening credit sequence of the fuse
being lit
set to lalo schifrin's original
composition was so popular that the
mission impossible theme placed on the
top 100 pop charts
the highest was number 41. in 1996
schifrin's instrumental theme was
refashioned to be more
dance oriented by u2's adam clayton and
larry malton jr
and that version made it all the way to
number 7 on the top 100 billboard pop
charts
[Music]
the original series began with the
character of dan briggs played by
stephen hill
but by season two he was replaced as the
head of imf
without explanation by jim phelps played
by peter graves
the only characters who appeared
throughout the entire series was the
electronic whiz barney coulier played by
greg morris
and the strong man willie artemidge
played by peter lupus
familiar faces like martin landau
leonard nimoy leslie ann warren and sam
elliott appeared in reoccurring roles
throughout the show's run
landau played role in hand a magician
and expert makeup artist dubbed the man
of a million faces
whose prosthetic mystique would receive
homage and the elaborate masks used in
the mission impossible film series
you might have noticed that the name
ethan hunt was nowhere in the television
series synopsis
taking a cue from how the television
series had briggs handing over the imf's
confidential dossier and exploding voice
tapes to a never before seen jim
phelps the 1996 film used an aged jim
phelps character
played by jon voight as the leader of a
new team where the new character of
ethan hunt
is perceived to be the sole survivor of
a mission that was meant to find a mole
within the imf
greg morris peter graves and martin
landau were all invited to reprise their
roles
but all refused when the various scripts
revealed that the reprised television
characters were either revealed to be a
traitor or murdered by someone within
the imf
while the script which was still being
rewritten while filming
used this to set up mission impossible
for a new generation
the original cast was not pleased with
the direction going to an
action-adventure spectacle
with their characters being left behind
however despite some cast misgivings the
first film did share
technological prowess with the original
series at a time when apple computers
were close to bankruptcy they turned to
hollywood as a final effort to promote
their new power book via hollywood films
the 15 million dollar buy to feature
their computers in mission impossible
and a cross-promotional ad campaign was
the first audience-facing deal made
between hollywood and tech
the man frequently on the computer
hacker luther stekel played by ving
rhames
is the only character other than ethan
hunt who appears in the entire mission
impossible film series
thank you for coming that's my job
the updating of the opening credits
music was the first hint as to how
director brian de palma would
approach bringing the film into a new
era by using the bones of the original
but adding
lots of modern tech wizardry the
emphasis according to cruz was put on
camera placement during elaborate stunts
which brought us the famous vault heist
in a temperature-controlled room
and concluded in an outrageous bullet
train sequence
while the initial film was thrilling and
immensely plotted the move towards a
colossal action spectacle officially
started when john woo
famous for hong kong actioners like hard
boiled and high concept hollywood
blockbusters like faceoff was hired to
direct the sequel
and though the bullet train sequence in
mission impossible was heavy on cgi
the stunt with the helicopter explosion
set crews on his
own mission to make impossible action
stunts more real
while mission impossible 2 is the only
mission film with a rotten critic
and audience score it is an important
shift for both the franchise and tom
cruise
from the second film onward action set
pieces were built around
a dangerous stunt that cruz himself
performs for heightened realism and
seemingly to test the actor's limits he
did spend two years learning to fly a
helicopter specifically to achieve a
stunt with him in the pilot seat in
fallout
ethan where are you i'm in a helicopter
but you can fly a helicopter
so let's run through one stunt mission
from each of the remaining films that
crews accepted the mission for
for our entertainment
impossible 2 saw crews getting
comfortable with big stunts that would
become
even bigger as the series went on
whereas jumping out of a helicopter in
mission impossible 2 was done via green
screen
just 18 years later in fallout cruz
would become the first actor to ever
complete a halo jump
on camera one of the very first big
stunts that cruz performed in the series
is in the opening credits scene where
he's free solo rock climbing and moab
utah's dead horse point state park
cruise did have a harness but no safety
net below and he climbed
2 000 feet when he jumps from one rock
to another
he did tear a muscle in his shoulder
from the landing
the most severe injury from doing his
own stunts on the series was
on fallout where a london footrace from
building to building
saw crews breaking his foot on an
awkward landing which delayed the shoot
for nine weeks
jj abrams made his feature film
directorial debut on mission impossible
3 after david fincher walked away due to
creative differences
cruz was a fan of abram's television
show alias which abrams had directed
multiple episodes of
abrams also picked up the pace from the
first two films and brought mission
impossible into a more fast and furious
action era
the third installment features lots of
tom cruise running tom cruise getting
thrown against cars
and landing back first on the roof of a
building in shanghai
a sequence that served as a bit of a
trial run for running down the tallest
building in the world in the next
installment
perhaps the most famous single sequence
in the series since the first film
arrives in ghost protocol
the sequence in question required crews
to wear a vest harness to climb 1700
of the 2 700 feet of the tallest
building in the world the burj khalifa
then crews had to fall four stories and
then run down the side of the building
before swinging
off a rope ever since ghost protocol
crews has gone to great lengths in an
attempt to outdo this stunt with major
set-piece swings in each movie
something that has his castmates in awe
since
since he hung off the burj khalifa and i
remember being in the audience the first
night i saw it
and the sense of like holy that the
audience
admitted when they saw him step off that
building it was like
this is key you know this degree of
authenticity
the fact that it's a practical stunt
done by the actor
it adds a degree of tension and
exhilaration that you don't get
when it's done by someone else or it's
done in a computer
rogue nation saw crews embrace the
continuous take approach
to keying the audience that they're
witnessing a practical stunt
this had crews trained to hold his
breath underwater for four to six
minutes during a pivotal underwater
rescue scene
while that sequence took 10 separate
shooting days to get it all in
continuous never coming up for air shots
it's the opening airplane stunt that
really makes our hair stand up
a shut airplane door does not deter
ethan hunt from completing his mission
and to open rogue nation
crews clung to the outside of a plane
door that took him 1000 feet above
ground at a speed of 115 miles per hour
as the actor hung to the outside and was
only held in by a
wire placed inside the plane you know
when you're on an airplane don't you
ever think like what's it would it be
like if you're on the wing
no i'm not i don't i don't think most
people do
i though we did it eight times we had to
do it eight times because we had to
adjust camera angle and you know you're
gonna do it you
have to get the right shot people could
dismiss it as crazy but
i think ultimately he's that
committed to his job he cares that much
about delivering in what is a very
crowded marketplace today
an authentic experience for the audience
a kind of sense of wonder and thrill
cruz has also rewarded director
christopher mcqueary for his ability to
safely pull off these feats
by handing over the keys to the mission
franchise with macquarie directing the
fifth and sixth film in the series
as well as the upcoming 7th and 8th
the 6th and most recent mission film is
the best reviewed
and audience rated in the series fallout
is
fully committed to being one action set
piece after another
in the streets of paris falling from the
sky and
even in public bathrooms but the most
perilous stunt for crews required two
years of helicopter training
with cameras rigged to the front the
crews angled himself while flying to
show that the actor was
actually at the controls and multiple
helicopters flying alongside for
coverage
all while capturing 360 degree corkscrew
dives
but just flying a helicopter wouldn't be
enough to get into the helicopter crews
had to climb a rope after it had already
taken off
it was hard the first person asked me
climbing up that rope
that was hard it's a rope climb man
let's run down what we know about the
next mission films
cruz and macquarie are bringing back
rebecca ferguson vanessa kirby
ving rhames simon pegg and angela
bassett for film seven and eight
along with newcomers to the franchise
hayley atwell palm clementife
shaya wingham and isaiah morales and
cruz is already hyping up his new most
dangerous stun
ever from film seven crews teased a
motorcycle jump off a cliff to empire
magazine
noting that the combination of norse
winds a helicopter flying above
and only six seconds to pull his
parachute made it quote
the most dangerous stunt he's done
writer director macquarie
shared a shot of the ramp and it's a
doozy this 7th mission impossible film
will be released in 2022 and the eighth
in 2023 but what about after that
i would never ask anyone i've the kind
of stuff that i've done
has been things that i've cultivated and
to have someone to say you have to do
this that's that's
like i don't know if i could ask anyone
to do that
uh even if they would want to do it and
people think they want to do it but once
they start
kind of doing it they realize how
challenging it is and it's
it's also look it's i've been doing this
since i was a little kid doing stuff
like this and i've been
really working on a one systems on how
to
make it so that you can actually survive
these things and and create those so
it's something of course my whole idea
was that the franchise would always go
on but i just
you know um they'd be nice
you know i hope you make like seven more
i speak to you you would be both
me you'll be both and then then i'll be
like okay
[Music]
you